President Trump and the White House are
still working to explain the president's
firing of FBI director James Comey Comey
himself is telling friends and former
colleagues not to get worked up about it
in a letter obtained by CBS News Comey
says I have long believed that a
president can fire an FBI director for
any reason or for no reason at all he
also says the American people should see
the FBI as a rock of competence honesty
and independence sources confirm to CBS
News that Comey had asked the Deputy
Attorney General for more resources to
help the FBI investigation of Russian
interference in the election the Justice
Department denies that Margot Brennan is
at the White House Margaret good morning
good morning well commis misstatements
to Congress last week and his comment
that he was made nauseous by the idea he
tipped the election did not endear him
to President Trump and that was just the
latest irritant in a relationship
already troubled by his refusal to back
up the president's wiretapping claims
back in his Virginia home on Wednesday
former director Comey sent a message of
encouragement to FBI colleagues
following his abrupt dismissal I'm not
going to spend time on the decision or
the way it was executed he wrote I hope
you won't either it's done and I will be
fine asked why he fired Comey President
Trump gave a terse reply as he wasn't
doing a good job very simply he was not
doing a good job
the Oval Office meeting with Richard
Nixon's Secretary of State Henry
Kissinger surprised reporters because
they expected to see the president's
scheduled guests Russian Foreign
Minister Sergey Lavrov but the press
wasn't allowed in for that meeting our
only glimpse came from these photos
posted by the Russian government showing
mr. Trump smiling and chatting with
Lavrov an ambassador Sarek is lyac who
is at the center of the firestorm that
led to former national security adviser
Mike Flynn's Oster the meeting with the
Russian diplomats had been arranged at
the request of Vladimir Putin beforehand
Lavrov feigned surprise at the news of
commis firing what's the fire
the White House admitted Wednesday that
the President had long been considering
ousting Comey
Deputy Attorney General Rod Rosenstein
and Attorney General Jeff Sessions met
with the president Monday they discussed
commis recent stumbles during Capitol
Hill testimony and recommended his
firing the White House says that the
president told Rosen Stein to put his
concerns in a memo released Tuesday that
cited commis handling of the Hillary
Clinton email investigation as grounds
for dismissal Rosen Stein on the job
just two weeks is a trump appointee
confirmed with broad bipartisan support
Gail he's now at the center of this
controversy all right Margaret thank you